But even if we do decide to turn off the alarm,
say after a hundred beeps regardless of someone turning it off or not,
we still need to copy and paste this If block a hundred times.
This is terrible.
There must be a solution.
Right? Well, Java does have a solution and it's called Loops.
Let's see how these work.
In Java, instead of using if,
you could use something called while.
Which is very similar to an if-condition.
Except that instead of checking for this condition once,
a while would continue to check that condition and apply that block here,
every time this condition is true.
So what happens in a code block like this,
is that the while we check if this on variable is true.
If it is, it would step inside,
run this entire code block,
go back up again, check on again.
If it's still true, then it would go down and repeat
this part over and over again until on is no longer true.
Then it just skips this part and continues.
This is why this is called While Loops.
Because it keeps looping over and over this code block
here as many times as needed while this condition still remains true.
This basically means that the single while block
here can replace all those repeated if blocks over there.
So instead of having to check our on variable multiple times in multiple if-blocks,
we can just check it in a while-loop.
And that would repeat this block here over and over until on is no longer true.
And because we're updating our on variable here using that checkAlarm function,
so eventually this checkAlarm function will
return false when someone turns the alarm off,
making our on variable false.
So at some point this while would quit.
Let's trace this function using the while loop and see how it works.
So, our updated function looks like so.
We start by creating this boolean on
and checking the alarm and then instead of having all these repeated if blocks,
we just have this single while loop that checks if on is true.
If so, we just start beeping and then we update on using the checkAlarm again.
Remember that checkAlarm function returns
a boolean which is true if the alarm is on and false,
if the alarm has been turned off.
Let's try this function and see how it works.
The first thing we do is we call our checkAlarm function to initialize our own variable.
Because it's six o'clock,
so our checkAlarm would actually return true.
Meaning that the alarm should start beeping now.
So our on variable here is true,
meaning that our while check here would be true.
So it would step inside and start beeping.
So, this would actually trigger our alarm clock to beep.
Then, we check the alarm again to update our on variable.
And because no one hit the snooze button yet,
so checkAlarms still returns true,
makes are on variable true.
Reach the end of our loop,
so we go back up and we check if that is true again.
Because on is true,
we step inside and call our beep function again,
which triggers our alarm clock to beep.
Then, we check the alarm again.
Now, imagine someone hits the snooze button now.
This means when we call check the alarm to see if the alarm is still on,
it actually returns false and therefore,
on also becomes false.
So, we've reached the end of our loop.
We go back up, we check this comparison again.
And because while is no longer true,
we do not step inside and hence, we don't beep.
So nothing happens anymore,
and this basically means that the while has ended,
and it will no longer check or try again.
It will just continue the program which doesn't have anything else so the function ends.
It seems like it's doing exactly what we expected.
This would continue to return true.
Setting our on variable to true.
Making our alarm beep for as long as it needs until
checkAlarm eventually decides to return false after someone hits the snooze button.
Perfect. You can see now that using a while loop can repeat something
for a variable number of times so we don't
have to know in advance how many times we need to repeat something.
We just put it in a while loop and make sure that
our condition would eventually turn false ending our loop.
Let's see a few more examples.